hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical and laboratory
studies of Zika virus infection
presented by dr. Charles - associate
professor of laboratory medicine and
medicine infectious diseases director
UCSF Abbott viral diagnostics and
Discovery Center associate director UCSF
School of Medicine we are excited to
bring you this educational webcast
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning I'm julissa Martha Roberts and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on this de button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and prop follow the
process of obtaining your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Charles Chiu I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
Thank You Julie and hello everyone I'd
like to talk to you today about clinical
and laboratory studies of Zika virus
infection Zika virus is a very broad
topic and I will be focused today on
describing studies of Zika virus
infection that are being done in my
laboratory and with collaborators I'd
like to begin with some disclosures I do
get research support for pathogen
discovery from Abbott Diagnostics and
research support for nanopore assay
development by that'll marry you so the
summary of my talk we'll start by
talking about Zika virus I'll provide
the introduction to the virus and will
also describe and give you some
information on why it is considered a
significant human pathogen and true and
emerging pathogen that only recently
we'd begun to appreciate I'll then
describe some in vitro cell culture
studies of zika virus infection that are
being done in my laboratory to better
understand how zika virus grows
themselves how it infects me themselves
and how it causes disease well then move
into a description of some animal models
of zika virus infection specifically
we'll be talking about a non-human
primate marmoset monkey model of zika
virus infection and how using this model
can help us better understand how zika
virus causes disease and and also
perhaps the development of a model that
could be used for vaccine and drug
development and finally we'll talk about
clinical and epidemiological studies of
zika virus infection using a novel
technique called metagenomics a way to
broadly analyze clinical samples for
really evidence of any of any kind of
infection whether it's a virus a
bacteria fungus or a parasite and using
zika virus infection as a model we'll
talk about specifically how these
technologies are being deployed in the
developing world
and how we could use it potentially in
the future as a way to address emerging
outbreaks loom from pathogens such as
Zika virus so let's start out by talking
about Zika virus
what is it well this is a virus in the
family flava Verde in the genus
flavivirus it is a flavivirus other
members of the flu virus genus include
West Nile virus Japanese encephalitis
virus st. Louis encephalitis virus a
dengue virus and yellow fever virus
these are all enveloped single-stranded
RNA viruses many have been associated
with human disease and certainly they
have also been described as as infecting
a wide variety of different animals
including vertebrates such as humans as
well as invertebrates such as mosquitoes
in particular many of these viruses are
known as vector borne pathogens meaning
that you acquire infection or you as a
person could be infected by exposure to
say a mosquito bite or bite of another
arthropod such as a tick what you see in
the lower left hand corner is actually
an an electron micrograph and this was
provided by the CDC this US Centers for
Disease Control which actually shows you
viral particles infecting a human cell
so the clinical presentation of acute
Zika virus infection is is is quite
interesting over 80% of these infections
are thought to be asymptomatic and what
that means is after a person gets bitten
by a mosquito and gets Zika virus
infection the person may not exhibit any
symptoms now in the roughly 20% of cases
where a patient is or a person is
infected person is symptomatic what you
can see are a variety of different
clinical syndromes that resemble an
acute febrile illness they include fever
rash headache
joint pain conjunctivitis or red eyes
and muscle pain laboratory findings from
any patients acutely infected with Zika
virus are usually normal although in
some cases you can see leukopenia which
is a low white blood cell count
thrombocytopenia a low platelet count or
allowed elevation in liver enzymes may
be a mild acute hepatitis however
recently it has been described severe
consequences of Zika virus infection in
particular during pregnancy in an
infected pregnant woman Zika virus
infection and during any time in her
pregnancy has been associated with what
a phenomenon called microcephaly now
this is a severe brain developmental
defect that can occur in babies of
pregnant women who are infected with
Zika virus infection and which will
describe in in more detail in later
slides another consequence of Zika virus
infection is the neurological
consequences is that some patients who
are infected with the Zika virus can
develop a severe neurological illness
called guillain-barre syndrome and this
is a paralytic illness in which there
can be slow a kind of neuro degeneration
it's an auto thought to be an autoimmune
disease where you develop antibodies
against against your neural cells
resulting in neurological disease and
open in some cases paralysis so this is
a severe consequence that can occur in
patients or in individuals who are
infected with Zika virus that notably
the Zika virus infection is the common
febrile or fever associate symptoms that
you get means that these in the device
infection can be clinically
indistinguishable from other
mosquito-borne infections now for
instance West Nile virus infection or
dengue virus infection these are both
flaviviruses also spread by mosquitoes
can essentially mimic Zika virus
infection and this poses a diagnostic
challenge for clinicians who are trying
to accurately diagnose and screen for
Zika virus infection in their
so whereas we Kivar has been found
well Zika virus was first identified in
Zika forest in Uganda Africa in 1947
from there it has been it is it has been
described in the late 70s in in parts of
Southeast Asia and Asia including
Pakistan Malaysia and Indonesia in 2007
there was actually a huge outbreak of
Zika virus infection in Micronesia and
yapped and the Yap island complex in the
Pacific Ocean and in 2013 it actually
spread to French Polynesia probably
received kind of the most notice in 2014
when there was a huge outbreak of Zika
virus infections in Brazil and Concordat
with that or at the time of the outbreak
was was also noted an increase in the
number of cases of microcephaly in
pregnant women from Brazil who were
infected with Zika virus in general
before 2015 Zika virus Zika outbreaks
really occurred on a sporadic basis
although currently outbreaks and cases
of Zika virus have been described
worldwide now this is a virus that
because it's spread by mosquitoes and in
particular the 80s Egypt I or 80s of a
pictus mosquitoes it's a virus that's
predominantly confined to tropical
regions of the world near the equator or
in some cases a farther away from the
equator and seeing that in the graph in
the plot below in the map below and the
map in the slide you can see that in in
purple highlighted areas where Zika
virus cases have been described by the
CDC and Zika has received kind of local
interest in the United States because
there have been evidence of local
mosquito-borne spread of Zika virus now
this is described as a toxin s cases of
Zika virus meaning that zika virus cases
that were obtained locally in your
native country this is as opposed to
more
cases of Zika virus diagnosed United
States which come from the exposure
outside of the United States where as a
returning traveler you get infected
outside the United States and then come
back to the United States if you are
screened for symptoms or if you test
positive for Zika virus it has been
described so far local spread of Zika
virus has been described really in two
regions of the United States
they include miami-dade County in
Florida and Brownsville Texas and as a
result of these local cases of
mosquito-borne spread the CDC had
recommended that pregnant women postpone
or cancel travel to these affected areas
now currently as of June 2nd 2017 the
CDC has actually lifted the yellow area
designation for travel travel
restrictions for pregnant women from
miami-dade County because it's been
thought that the zika virus infected
mosquitoes have been eradicated from
that County however there still is a
recommendation that pregnant women avoid
travel to Brownsville Texas this is a
slide that shows you the kind of the
mosquito the 80s a [ __ ] time mosquito
that has been most commonly associated
with Zika transmission this is a virus
that is spread most commonly through
mosquito bites however it also has been
described vertical transmission of Zika
virus from a pregnant woman to her fetus
in some cases resulting in kind of
severe neurological consequences such as
microcephaly it sexual transmission of
Zika virus has also been described a
both male to female and female to male
through sexual contact and this is
rather and kind of an unusual phenomenon
because it has not really been described
for other flaviviruses it really has
only been described for Zika virus and
there have been some rare cases of
laboratory exposure by working with Zika
virus infecting materials Zika has also
been shown to be spread through blood
transfusion however there have been no
reports of infants who are who have
gotten Zika virus through breastfeeding
[Music]
this slide gives you an example of
congenital zika syndrome and this is
probably the most striking and perhaps a
severe manifestation of Zika virus
infection this is due to vertical
transmission of the virus from an
infected pregnant mom to the fetus and
it has been linked to Zika virus
infection has been linked to
abnormalities in brain development the
most prominent is microcephaly where you
can see that babies are born with
abnormally small heads but in addition
to that this isn't it's not just the
size of the head but it also it's it
represents a developmental delay in
general of neural development so many of
these babies are are born for instance
with severe developmental disability and
only now are we starting to appreciate
kind of the long-term consequences as
these babies grow older of having
microcephaly the
what the congenital consequences of Zika
virus or potential consequences of Zika
virus infection otherwise known as
congenital zika syndrome has also been
associated with miscarriages and
stillbirths in infected women who are
pregnant women who are infected with
Zika virus the Zika virus in adults has
also been associated with the severe
neurological illness called gamma ray
syndrome now this is an uncommon
autoimmune disease of the nervous system
resulting in damage to nerve cells
resulting in muscle weakness and
potentially paralysis in some cases the
process which usually begins in the arms
and the legs peripherally can become so
severe that patients will be unable to
leave on their own and they would
require a ventilator in most cases
Gyan bere syndrome is reversible with
and the treatment is mainly supportive
although in some cases there have been
long-term effects from Gyan beret
syndrome in some cases deaths as well
now Gabriel syndrome has been strongly
associated with Zika virus infection in
both children and adults although
similar to congenital zika virus in
Jerome it's unknown what proportion of
people who are infected Zika virus
actually get Yarber a syndrome and the
CDC is continuing the United States
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention is continuing to investigate
the link between G hombre syndrome and
Zika to learn more about this syndrome
and association of Zika virus infection
now the Zika virus diagnostic testing is
is typically there are their two main
tests culturing for the virus in which
you try to grow the virus is generally
not used clinically so I won't talk any
more about that there is an acute phase
of the virus which of the infection
meaning less than or equal to one week
after the initial mosquito bite or
acquisition of the disease in this case
it is possible that you could detect
Zika virus by doing polymerase chain
reaction testing specifically looking
for viral nucleic acid or raro RNA in
blood saliva or urine the Center for
Disease Control and Prevention has a
Zika virus assay that actually consists
of two PCR reactions and they also have
what's known as a trial plex PCR assay
which can detect three different árbol
viruses or other pod borne viruses
simultaneously zika chikungunya and
dengue virus now after two weeks however
the virus is typically not detectable in
blood or in other bodily fluids by the
use of PCR testing so in that case we
have to resort to a test called an
antibody or serological tests
specifically be look for IgM antibody to
Zika virus this has been problematic a
little problematic given that the
antibody test has cross reactivity with
other flaviviruses including yellow
fever virus West Nile virus and
the virus in other words what this means
is that you can have a positive test for
a surgical test for Zika virus but it
may not be specific for Zika virus it
may simply reflect that prep at prior or
recent exposure to dengue virus for
instance and because it lacks
specificity this really poses a kind of
an ongoing challenge for how do we
actually develop diagnostic tests for
Zika virus are both sensitive and
specific there is a confirmatory test
called the plaque reduction
neutralization test for Zika which is
called print'
this is also an antibody test intends to
be more specific and yet it still has
cross reactivity with these other lady
viruses so I'm going to go into kind of
the research that we're currently doing
in the laboratory to sort of answer some
key questions involving Zika virus I'm
going to answer the following five
questions first we want to potentially
answer the question of does Zika virus
infect mature brain neurons and spinal
cord cells you know the previously
mentioned one of the consequences of
Zika virus infection adults izv okay
potential consequences is gamma ray
syndrome this is a disease of spinal
cord cells so what we want to see is you
know SSO is is does Zika virus directly
infect spinal cord cells and perhaps
that might be a mechanism by which it
may result in gamma ray syndrome is
gamma ray syndrome really an autoimmune
or an antibody response to the infection
and whereas where Zika virus is not
directly infecting those cells similarly
we want to know whether or not Zika
virus infects mature brain neurons and
this is important and what I define as
mature as differentiated brain neurons
and this is important because of this
association between Zika virus infection
and fetal neurological defects such as
microcephaly we already know that that
Zika virus need data from other groups
has already shown that the Zika virus
can infect for instance fetal or
developing neurons but can Zika virus
also infect kind of mature neurons
that's a key question that we'd like to
answer we also
in answering the question of can we
develop a non-human primate or a monkey
model of Zika virus that replicates the
human disease and the purpose of
developing a non-human primate model is
that we could potentially use this to
better understand how Zika virus causes
microcephaly and potentially better on
better this could spur the development
of effective drugs and vaccines that
could be tested in this non-human
primate model that could be used to
prevent the consequences of Zika virus
infection we also want to do genetic or
genomic studies of Zika virus and the
purpose of this is to determine or
assess how Zika virus is evolving and
spreading in americas the third question
is we want to see is there a human gene
signature for zika virus that has
diagnostic and/or prognostic utility i
previously mentioned one of the
diagnostic dilemmas of zika virus is
that PCR testing for instance is only
good or typically thought to be good
within the first week or two whereas at
the antibody of serological testing
lacks specificity can we find
potentially a human gene signature that
will allow us to diagnose zika virus
within the window period the period of
time they are both PCR and serology is
not very useful in diagnosing the
disease and this is one of the kind of
key challenges that are facing those of
us who are working on Zika virus
Diagnostics and then finally using zika
virus as an example of an outbreak
pathogen can we develop rapid diagnostic
tests for zika virus and other fever
associated illnesses that can be used in
the field can we develop a test for
instance that we could bring to Africa
that we could lay in the Brazil or that
we could bring to other areas around the
world to be able to do testing not only
for Zika virus but really to be able to
do differential diagnosis of all several
infections especially those that are
caused by um that are vector-borne
caused by bites of mosquitoes and ticks
so I'll talk first about Zika virus
infection of differentiated or mature
neurons and they'd like to highlight
that this work was done primarily by dr.
Claudia
summer teen in my laboratory who is a
PhD researcher and the premise behind
that these studies are that we really
need to understand in vitro cell culture
models to better study Zika virus
pathogenesis and also to understand you
know how Zika virus infect cells and the
spectrum of Zika virus infection what
you actually see in this image here is
this is actually an electron micrograph
of zika virus infecting a human neural
cell line which I'll go into shortly and
where you see kind of the dark particles
which I'll actually show you here you
can see here basically focus on dark
particles and each of those particles is
a particle of Zika virus and I want to
say that we're not the only ones that
are working obviously on Zika virus
there have been a huge number of papers
that have come out in recent in over the
past year specifically looking at Zika
virus infection of different needle
cells when you chosen to focus
specifically on mature differentiate
neurons and spinal cord cells of which
there's much less data that's been
available that's available in the
literature so this is kind of the study
design what we do is we actually plate
cells and these cells are neurological
cells neuroblastoma cells in the cell
line SH - s y5 y these are neuroblastoma
cells so they're adult tumor cells that
have been immortalized and cultured in
and basically propagated in cell lines
what we do is we plate these cells and
then we infect we use a virus to infect
these cells if you start out by
infecting undifferentiated cells meaning
that cells have not been differentiated
into mature neurons and then we infect
differentiated cells one the possibility
what we did then do is we actually
collect the cells and we do one test
that we do is called quantitative rt-pcr
we actually look the levels of the
as it grows inside of these cells and
hopefully will yield expect to see as he
had expect to see an increase in qrt-pcr
viral loads over time as the virus grows
and infects these cells and then we also
do a plaque assay we also collect these
samples for doing staining so that we
can see for instance directly visualize
the cells growing in cell culture so
this is an example of some of the
results that we have from the study what
you actually see on the right are panels
of different cells so what you see
actually see on the upper row on the top
row is a panel showing an
undifferentiated cell line and you see
infection of a none differential cell
line with a by inoculating the cell line
with zika virus in the middle row is
actually a potential cell line which is
basically a neurological basically a
neuron that's mature and then in the
bottom row we actually see viral cells
which is a common monkey cell line
that's known to be infected by Zika
virus so this is actually a positive
control in what you can see in all
instances if you look if you focus on
kind of the panel on the right you can
see that in areas marked red that
actually marks areas of cells that are
infected with Zika virus so what you can
see is that there is some infection
undifferentiated cells it's not that
much though that appears that very few
of the cells are infected however once
the cells differentiate or mature you
can see that more cells are infected and
so this is is really kind of this data
has really really showed us that mature
cells indeed neoblasts neural cells are
indeed infected by the virus so we
attempted to actually quantify in terms
of what how many of these cells are
actually infected following zika virus
infection so what you can see here is
that with kind of an undifferentiated
cells and these are cells that are not
yet mature they've not differentiated
yet you can see that
two of them are infected however once
you differentiate them using either 2%
fetal bovine serum or this chemical
called retinoic acid
yeah these both differentiate themselves
you can see that you seem much more
infection as shown by what these graphs
join the percent of cells are infected
in terms of focus forming units or ffu
as well as kind of the degree of kind of
green fluorescence that you can actually
see by staining these cells correlating
with the increases in infection we also
see increases in tighter so so along
with the kind of increased number of
cells we can also see an increase in the
amount of virus that can actually be
detected in supernatant from these cells
and this is also additional evidence
that shows that these cells are infected
we also did some experiments showing or
studies showing that various strains of
Zika virus are infectious to these cell
lines so for instance the Uganda string
which was a vigil 1947 strain of zika
virus as well as a 2015 proto RICO
strain Malaysian strain Cambodian strain
and probably the most recent 2016
bazzill strain these are these viruses
are different strains of Zika virus are
all able to infect the neuroblastoma
cell lines or the mature different
gender ons and when we did electron
microscopy of these infected cells we
saw that you could actually visualize
the particles and that particles appear
to accumulate in Golgi bodies Golgi
bodies are cell structural components
where the proteins human proteins are
processed and also viral proteins tend
to be processed and we actually found
that Zika virus appears to accumulate in
these Golgi bodies and actually appears
to distort their architecture of the
Golgi bodies notably this is also seen
in other flavor viral infections such as
hepatitis C virus which which is also a
other flower of the flavor elections as
well as hepatitis C virus I'd like to
move into kind of a non-human primate or
marmoset monkey model Zika virus
infection and I'd like to acknowledge
some of the collaborators that were
working with on this they include the
Texas biomedical Health Research
Institute researchers doctors gene
Patterson Suzette tardes and we see of
the donee dr. Chrissy a guard at the
Baylor College of Medicine dr. Julian
Luthor for the university llinois and my
laboratory so one common question is why
do we actually want to develop a new
world monkey model Zika virus infection
I can tell you that many groups are
working on different monkey models most
of the focus on monkey models or
non-human primate models of Zika virus
infection have been with Lisa or old
world monkey macaques so there are some
advantages to using kind of marmoset
swine is that these new world monkeys
are easier to house and he'll cause
because of their small size if you
wanted to test say a novel vaccine or
therapeutic they may really decrease
volume requirements for doing so they
don't appear to harbor infectious
disease agents that are transmissible to
humans like herpes virus B which is
spread by or it is potentially
transmissible from old-world monkeys the
mono set monkeys can be maintained in
natural social groupings so you can
study for instance potentially studies
of say sexual transmission of Zika virus
and it's also been described by my
collaborators that marmoset monkeys are
rarely infected by a variety of human
viral pathogens so it's a it's also the
fact that these monkeys are endemic to
affected areas of say Brazil of South
America so potentially they may
constitute a reservoir for the virus in
the wild and finally each pregnancy are
typically multiple births you can have
dizygotic or twin births or in some
cases triplets or quadruplets in the
monkeys and it may make it easier to
study for instance Zika virus induced
neural fetal defects so disadvantage
though is that we have it's less
commonly used in United States there are
very few institutions such as the Texas
biomedical research institute that have
access to these monkeys for research and
the small size of the monkeys limits a
clinical sample volume in the scope of
procedures
you could do so this is the study
collection protocol what we do is we
actually inoculate these marmoset
monkeys with Zika virus and we collect a
variety of clinical samples as you can
see here we like to serve understand you
know how does the virus infect these and
how long does a virus persist in these
body fluids following infection we were
able to show immediately that actually
that this virus is infectious to
marmoset monkeys which was not a
guaranteed thing it does what you can
see is in all of the four monkeys that
we looked at the a monkey amounted a
very strong antibody neutralizing
antibody response to the virus and in
fact when we challenged the monkey with
previously inoculated monkey with
another a dose of the of the virus you
actually saw that the antibodies didn't
rely think antibody titer increased even
more so there was probably an
enhancement by a reach allen geing with
another dose of the virus when you look
at sort of the viral expression kind of
in different tissues and bodily fluids
from from these monkeys you can see that
it does appear to persist about a week
or so in serum as you can see in the
upper left corner and then it does
appear to persist longer up to two weeks
in urine and saliva and then
sporadically detected in feces and in
semen and semen swabs now this is what's
interesting is that this actual these
kinetics of the virus in different body
fluids appears to mimic very well what
we had see in humans so in humans for
instance typically you can find the
virus in blood in the first week but and
you could probably it persist for longer
periods of time in urine saliva and
semen and appears at this this
particular monkey model is is a good
mimic or replicate of what you might see
in human infection meaning that it might
be a suitable model to use for studying
human infection the only thing that's
also notable is that all four of the
monkeys who are not which were
inoculated they did not develop any
symptoms and
this is also in line with the fact that
80% of human infections of Zika virus
are asymptomatic this is a view of some
of the using cytokine profiling we're
able to actually look at some of this
some of the proteins or cytokines that
are expressed in response to Zika virus
infection and I don't want to go too
much into this I do what I do want to
say that some interferon associated
genes are do appear to be induced by
Zika virus infection such as interferon
gamma and MIG these genes and cytokines
have previously been described actually
in the context of various viral
infections and though they can do is we
could actually do what we call
transcriptome analysis which is instead
of looking at say a small panel of
cytokines we can actually look at every
single gene that's being expressed by by
in tissues from these infected marmosets
and what we can see and this is data
that's coming from blood from whole
blood from these marmosets is that
there's a very strong interferon
signalling pathway response that is
associate with Zika virus infection now
this is actually well known it's well
known that interferon signalling is
involved in many viral infections
ranging from flaky viruses like Zika
like West Nile virus to influenza virus
but what it was interesting to see
though that that we could identify a
signature a host response in this case
that would be hopefully predictive of
Zika virus infection that could give us
insights into how the virus is infecting
these monkeys and this gives you an
example of some of the unsafe that we
can develop so if you look at day three
for instance you can see that much of
what's being induced on a gene level is
the type 1 interferon pathway but if you
look on day 9 you actually see that you
actually see both type 2 and type 1 so
type 1 is on the right type 2 is on the
left that you kind of see now induction
of the type to interferon pathway and
that actually turns out to be
significant from a mechanistic
standpoint because it is is now thought
actually that in not in various
non-human pride
and in the heat and human infections
that the virus may actually inhibit
parts of the type one pathway meaning
that what happens is that the virus that
the that that perhaps that the human
whose response or the in this case the
marmoset was response to the viral
infection would have to go through a
different pathway which would be the
type two pathway on the left the other
thing that we've shown also by doing
these studies is that human placental
trophoblasts appear to be permissive for
Zika virus infection so this was a study
that was done by my collaborator
Christie a garden you can see here that
she was able to show that human
placental trophoblast which are cells
that are derived the key cell in the
placenta in the human placenta that they
are infected by Zika virus and similarly
we've been able to show enlarged sets
that marmoset placental cells are also
infected and there is now our kind of a
growing hypothesis among many groups
that perhaps it's the placenta the
maternal placenta in the mom that
maintains the virus in the setting or
maintains the viral infection or
replication in the setting of a
pregnancy and it is possible that the
placenta plays a critical role in
maintaining the virus in pregnant women
until the fetus is infected so the the
idea of maybe that if we could develop a
way to prevent or to mitigate potential
infection we might be able to prevent
some of the consequences that are seeing
with say microcephaly in the children of
Zika virus infected mothers and we're
currently doing work comparing for
instance of the placental cells and
their infective defect ability by Zika
virus among marmosets among baboons and
among humans initially I think the
take-home message is that all of these
placental cell types whether they come
from monkeys or where they come from
humans appear to be effective and highly
infective oh by Zika virus I want to
present also some very very recent
unpublished data showing congenital zika
virus infection in female marmoset
and the idea behind this is we want to
demonstrate or replicate kind of Zika
virus associated microcephaly in this
case in an animal model so the nutritive
time I won't go over the the exact the
protocol here but the general idea is
that we took two marmoset stem Omar says
pregnant P Morris's infected with Zika
virus and followed them when they
fortunately fetal explosion occurred the
OPA that was me doing miscarriages in
both of these pregnancies fetal
explosion occurred about about 21 days
after we inoculated those female
pregnant monkeys with Zika virus one
thing though that we did note is that in
but in both the in both of the fetuses
from these mama sets we did know that
you could detect the virus in pretty
much multiple tissues but the tissues
are primarily there the fetal tissues
placental tissues and then some Vaali
secretions from them from the feet from
them from the mom as well as from the
dam as well as in lymph nodes and this
shows you kind of the spectrum of the
virus so it seems to replicate what we
see in male mama sets in that you can
see persistence of the virus in urine
and perhaps some only of kind of Armenia
in the first week following infection
but notably what we did see was that it
appeared that there was congenital Zika
virus infection in these mo marmosets
you can see here that this is a view of
in this this is a view of kind of the
fetal head and the fetus from these the
miscarriages that occurred in these
inoculated monkeys but interesting
enough the biparietal diameter which is
the diameter circumferential diameter of
the head
I was actually 50% of that expected and
this is actually what we feel to be
actually the first but potential
demonstration or demonstration of a
potential microcephaly in a non-human
primate or monkey model that may be
attributed hopefully attributed Zika
virus infection though this was actually
only two cases and we're currently doing
kind of further studies to
to confirm or to replicate with the
distance results and the finally I want
to go into the fact that we're also
interested in looking at the virus by
studying these non-human primate models
so we're working with dr. Larkin and
Cowan Rome rompe at UC Davis they have
at least separate rhesus macaque model
of Zika virus infection and that you say
enough what we've noted in their model
is that there was a mutation that
appeared to be induced by inoculating
these pieces of the cax with this virus
and interesting enough this mutation is
actually was seen in in only in mothers
or fetuses who are infected whose fetus
has died as a result of the infection
and what's interesting is that this
particular mutation has also been seen
in human cases of actual Zika virus
microcephaly induced microcephaly that
have been described in such as in this
paper in the New England Journal of
Medicine when they seekest the virus
from this mom this human mom with who
had a child with microcephaly they
actually found that that virus had the
exact same mutation as a mutation that
we see in the rhesus macaque model and
this is actually highly very exciting
data because it really suggests to us
that there may be a possibility that
there may be specific mutations or
variants of the virus that may be linked
to or may be causative of microcephaly I
want to end by talking about a briefly
about our efforts to do metagenomic
surveillance of zika virus infection so
my mother Troy is interested in what we
called metagenomic next generation
sequencing this is a very broad approach
we're actually taking a fish net and the
idea is to instead of typical ways of
diagnosing infections by looking for one
target at a time we want to take a huge
fish net and be able to capture the
entire spectrum of organisms that cause
infectious diseases in a single test or
a single assay and if these are the
principle that all microbes bacteria
fungi viruses and parasites can be
uniquely identified by their DNA or RNA
in a principle there's no particular
reason why we can simply implement a
single test to identify
these microbes that cause infectious
diseases and let's make this approach
possible over the past couple years have
been the development of pipelines by
several groups we have this sur peopie
plane that was developed in my
laboratory that can enable us to analyze
say a hundred million two hundred
million three hundred million sequence
reads within two hours and be able to
then determine whether there are any
pathogens or read sequencing weeds the
pathogen said that that cause infectious
diseases in clinical samples we actually
developed a clinical workflow in the
laboratory and we actually are running a
clinical test now based on submitted
genomic sequencing that can detect all
viruses bacteria fungi and parasites in
a single test now this is for the
purposes of diagnosing meningitis and
encephalitis from spinal fluid although
we're developing currently clinically
validating this test for other
indications so I won't talk specifically
of how we've applied this technique
metagenomic sequencing the general idea
is that you want to take a clinical
sample blood saliva respiratory
secretions urine and be able to sequence
all the DNA and RNA stamp in that sample
be able to then identify non-human reads
that may correspond to potential
pathogens
now we developed a method that we can
couple this metagenomic approach with
doing specific enrichment for Zika virus
and by doing so the idea is that we
might be able to not only detect Zika
virus but be able to assemble the entire
genome of the virus and we be able to
show for instance these are actual cases
from a Bahia Brazil of Zika virus
infection where although we have very
low titers of the virus we can still
recover most if not all of the genome by
using these techniques and we were able
to us to use this or apply this in the
case of Bahia Brazil where we identified
that there was a specific circulating
strain in Bahia Brazil identified using
meta genomic sequencing with enrichment
we identified one strain as you can see
there which is color again in sort of
the pinkish color there's one clade or
one group of the virus that appeared to
be inherent
here Brazil and this is only
identifiable by the use of whole genome
sequencing and metagenomic sequencing
notably but the other Zil is is an
interesting state because that that
actually is a Province in Brazil that is
most affected by micro sneak associated
microcephaly in fact this is the
province within Brazil that reported the
greatest number of cases of microcephaly
and as you can see here we the first
case of this Zika virus associated
microcephaly was actually reported in
early 2015 and and you can see there
that it actually correlates very well if
you look at a previous slide with the
emergence of the virus occurring in 2014
so by the use of essentially genomic
sequencing the virus we were able to
basically track how the virus emerged in
Bahia Brazil and also on how it became
apparent that the virus was associated
cases of microcephaly in humans I want
to go into some other applications of
using metagenomic sequencing one idea
behind the genomic sequencing is that
you can do what we call transcriptome
analysis and it's a very powerful
approach where we actually look at human
gene expression in response to
infections such as by Zika virus and our
hypothesis here is that the
transcriptome of Zika virus patients can
help us identify blood biomarkers that
might be able to be predictive of novel
microcephaly but also Gambhir a syndrome
and we can perhaps develop this as a
diagnostic test this is actually been
shown and perhaps that we might be able
to adopt our lessons from Lyme disease
we're currently actually working on a
separate project by dr. Jerome bouquet a
postdoc in my laboratory on developing a
panel that can diagnose Lyme disease by
the use of looking at the hosts response
now this is a novel approach because
we're not trying to diagnose the disease
by detecting the pathogen or pathogen
nucleic acid we're actually diagnosing
the disease by looking at the specific
pattern of human genes in response to
that infection and is it specific enough
so that we could diagnose that disease
we'd be able to show for instance by
just looking at human host response we
can develop a panel for Lyme disease
diagnosis as
very good performance sensitivity
specificity and accuracy currently this
is a development as a clinical test for
acute Lyme disease and we want to apply
this now to zika virus infection because
it would be great if we for instance
could develop a test that could help me
prognostic and help us determine you
know whether or not a woman is infected
with Zika virus whether or not she has
her infected baby is a risk of
developing you know Zika virus infection
or whether Zika virus infection of
microcephaly and or whether or not a
patient's or risk of developing severe
disease or outcomes from Zika virus
infection and I'm going to talk to very
briefly about some of the clinical
samples we analyzed today we actually
looked and we identified some
differentially expressed genes as a
result and notably one of the genes
actually was related with a neurological
gene that's only found in neurons and
this is work which is currently ongoing
but it's all hope that we may it may
yield some insights into developing a
diagnostic specific virus infection I
want to end by talking about some very
exciting work that we're doing on
differential diagnosis of tropical
illnesses and which include Zika virus
and one of the challenges for us when
we're trying to diagnose infections in
the tropics is that the same clinical
syndrome can be replicated that can be
seen in a variety of different
infections whether the bacterial with a
viral or whether they're other or even
non infectious and whether the other
challenge that's focused specifically of
Zika virus is that Tydeus or Zika virus
are tend to be very very low in the
setting of a key infection so we can see
is on the left with Ebola virus the
cycle thresholds are very low mean that
the titers and infected people or the
loads in affected people are very high
that's the case that Ebola or Zika virus
the titers are low so what we've done is
we've actually coupled the use of
metagenomic detection to detect
everything but we've been able to add
specific targets targeted primaries to
increase sensitivity so the idea behind
this is we want to be able to a niche
these metagenomic libraries to be able
to check something like Zika virus is
very very high sensitivity but at the
same time we don't sacrifice the ability
to detect off target
targets like in this case HIV and we'd
be able to show that this approach can
actually enable us to get a sensitivity
almost comparable or equivalent to
direct PCR testing for Zika virus as you
can get very high coverage in some cases
we can recover the entire genome as you
can see here this is where where I'm now
a mapping Ross metagenomic sequencing
needs onto the viral genome of Zika
virus we've actually also been able to
use this to actually in a mannequin
preparation to describe for instance by
doing whole genome sequencing from low
titer samples on how the virus is
spreading and evolving in Mexico and in
Central America
so this is the summary of viral genome
sequencing we've adopted the spiked in
primer technique which is cheap and fast
and easy to do it's it tends to be
having many advantages and I'm I finally
want to end by the very last thing is we
want to apply this technique to be able
to diagnose in real time pathogens in
the setting with febrile illness
including Zika virus and this is done
with dr. Wayne dang a postdoctoral
fellow in my laboratory so what we've
done is we actually use a little common
ion sequencer which actually is a
sequencer which is pocket-sized powered
by the USB port in your laptop and
essentially way you can do a sequencing
on the fly using this instrument we were
able to actually take a blood sample and
actually go from a sample to processing
it to sequencing and getting an answer
in under three hours so potentially this
may be a test that will Mabel us to
identify essentially all organisms
within three hours from clinical samples
we published some data suggesting that
we could for instance identify chinguga
virus on the left in Ebola virus on the
right within six and eight minutes of
starting sequencing and let us show you
here is a brief video showing how we
have actually been able to apply this to
zika virus so what you're seeing here is
i'm actually starting the sequencing run
this is a blood sample from a sample
that's infected with that has HIV and
zika virus in it we can stack HIV and we
can also detect zika virus at a lower
titer using
within essentially fifteen minutes of
starting sequencing so nanopore
sequencing it does have several
advantages and I already mentioned most
of them it's portable it's pocket-sized
we can sequence RNA potentially in
addition DNA potentially they're very
fast turnaround times we could use these
in the field and in fact we've actually
deployed some of these nano port
sequences to Brazil and to Mexico to do
Zika virus sequencing the costs of the
sequencing tend to still be high and the
error rates are still high so these may
be potential disadvantages before we can
sort of see these technologies being
used materially in clinical setting I
want to end by acknowledging of the
multiple research collaborators and
scientists who work with me on this
they include members of my laboratory
including they're listed there support
from avid diagnostics we work at the
University of Calgary Davis lark coffee
and corn from rompe on the rhesus
macaque model Texas biomedical research
institute and Baylor School of Medicine
on marmoset model of Zika virus
infection the University of Oxford on
Zika virus genome sequencing and
analysis the calculate Department of
Public Health on investigation of
outbreaks Mexico the National Autonomous
University of Mexico on studying Zika
virus evolution as well as collaborators
in Barbados and Brazil and finally I
would like to acknowledge funding for my
research which includes funding from the
NIH the National Institutes of Health as
well as from Abbott Laboratories
thank you very much and I would be happy
to take any questions
Thank You dr. chu for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question we will follow up with you via
email after the presentation let's get
started
our first question is what are the most
significant questions remaining
regarding a Zika virus so that's a good
question but what are what are kind of
the challenges that are remaining
involving Zika virus well there's so
much about the virus we don't understand
you know we don't really understand why
is it that some patients pregnant women
who are infected with Zika virus
actually have babies who have
microcephaly although this association
has now been proven and confirmed we
don't know what what is the risk of
microcephaly in a pregnant woman who's
infected with Zika virus we still don't
understand the risk of similarly the
risk of gamma ray syndrome in a patient
who is infected with Zika virus we don't
really understand kind of the mechanism
of sexual transmission of Zika virus why
is it that this is among all flavivirus
appears to be the only virus that
appears to be sexually transmitted and I
think what's really lacking with Zika
virus is that we really lack an
effective vaccine which is what we
really need to prevent these infections
ultimately as well as potential
treatments or or therapeutics that might
be used to either prevent or to mitigate
some of these consequences of Zika virus
infection and really what is really
needed it's kind of a broad-based
approach which involves both cell
culture understanding kind of the basic
biology of the virus of animal models
that could be used such as mouse models
and
give me primer muggles such as Aramis
that motto I I previously talked about
that could be used to to develop and
test drugs and vaccines candidate drugs
and vaccines as well as better ways to
diagnose the disease and to follow
patients who are infected with the virus
thank you the next question is why
aren't we seeing ongoing cases of Zika
in previous countries affected by the
outbreak this is a very interesting
question it is well it is now well
described differences that we have seen
very very few cases in Brazil we're
seeing very very few cases in areas that
have previously been essentially
severely affected by the Zika virus and
outbreak like Puerto Rico for instance
where much of the population may have
been exposed to the virus so whereas in
2014-2015 there were thousands of cases
in Brazil right now we're only seeing a
handful of cases in these locations now
we don't really know the actual answer
to this although it has been speculated
and I think there is some data to
support this that there may be of what
we call heard to be the effect meaning
that patients in these exposed areas or
individuals in these exposed population
have already been exposed to the virus
and therefore have developed an immunity
so are less likely to see cases of
transmission if they already immune I do
have to stress however that is unknown
whether or not kind of repeat infection
from Zika virus will help will prevent
is possible or whether or not it will it
will prevent any of the cont of the
downstream consequences of Zika virus
infection which is why I still feel that
efforts to develop a drugs or vaccines
to prevent infection in the first place
are still needed
thank you we wrap up with one more
question and that question is what kind
of diagnostics are needed for this
developing world in preparation for
outbreaks such as Zika virus that's a
great question in that's a great
question and what we really need for a
new Diagnostics for dealing with kind of
these new outbreaks we need broad-based
Diagnostics that can really detect all
types of organisms that cause these
diseases it's not just viruses that
cause disease although viral outbreaks
have probably received the most
publicity there have been cases of say
bacterial outbreaks there was actually
recently described in ongoing case cases
of a new fungal pathogen called Candida
aureus which has caused several
hospital-associated outbreaks throughout
the United States which is an ongoing
kind of outbreak situation that's been
monitored by the Centers for Disease
Control so what we really need are for
for doing this kind of surveillance or
being able to develop diagnostic tests
for for identifying outbreak patently is
you need tests that can identify the
full spectrum of infect infectious
pathogens that can cause these outbreaks
in other words we need a test that can
detect all viruses bacteria fungi and
parasites you know of which perhaps a
meta genomic test might be a suitable
candidate for doing so in addition you
need to have a test that could
potentially detect organisms or protect
detect sequences from organisms that are
potentially novel it's been well
described that many of these many of
these emerging outbreak pathogens
they're they either have have they're
either
they either arise from animals or they
haven't been
or their uncommon or they haven't been
described very well in the past and they
have been characterized very well and as
a result what you really want a
broad-based unbiased diagnostic tests
that could detect not only known
pathogens or well-characterized
pathogens but also kind of these novel
pathogens a good example of a novel
pathogen would be something like SARS
coronavirus which was a credible strain
that had previously not been appreciated
as causing infections in humans but
which is responsible for a global
outbreak you know several years ago so
what we would need is we think you need
probably broad-based diagnostic tests
that can detect the full spectrum of
pathogens as well as tests that could be
applied in the point-of-care sort of
directly in pandemic hotspots so that
diagnosis can be made quickly and
interventions public health and
infection control interventions could be
instituted immediately and in that way
hopefully be able to either prevent or
mitigate the spread of a potential
outbreak
thank you once again dr. chu I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
14th 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting me know when this
webcast will be available to replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you
against them goodbye